tout tourne autour de lui marc bibeau
ses avocats disait vouloir préserver sa
réputation contre une médiatisation
d'allégations non vérifiés et basé sur
du ouï-dire les documents rappelle le
contexte de l'intervention policière au
bureau du grand argentier du parti
libéral tout a commencé en 2012 par une
enquête sur une subvention autorisé par
la ministre nathalie normandeau
dix-huit mois plus tard celle enquête
machuret là on s'intéresse directement
au financement du parti libéral sur une
période de 11 ans le financement dit
sectorielle celui qui vient des
entreprises et elles seront nombreuses à
attirer l'attention des policiers
les enquêteurs accumulaient les
témoignages entendus aussi à la
commission charbonneau rosaire sauriol
par exemple de la firme dessau lira aux
policiers de sault financer plus le plq
car lorsqu'ils sont au pouvoir les
ministres attire plus les gens
d'affaires ensuite ils peuvent
influencer les orientations politiques
dans lesquels ils ont une expertise paul
la fleur de bpr qui dit clairement que
son entreprise financée au plq pour le
réseautage et qu'il n'aurait jamais
voulu prendre le risque de ne plus
financer le parti et ce risque c'est un
certain john drake de l'entreprise rsw
qui le détail acheter sur tric puisse
représenter le parti libéral pu tenir ce
discours là il raconte que marc bibeau a
constaté que sa firme avait beaucoup de
contrat avec hydro-québec que d'autres
firmes verser de l'argent au plq et
aimerait bien avoir des contrats qu'ils
voulaient que rsw lui remettre des
chèques directement monsieur dick et à
vue du trafic d'influencé et s'est dit
choqué mangeant le borsalino giuseppe
borsellino qui affirme qu il contribuer
au financement politique pour bing team
rester en vie qu'ils considèrent que
plus il donnait plus il avait de gros
contrats
c'est lui qui nous avait donné cet
échange précieux à propos du bateau de
tony accurso bateau effets de ce bateau
le problème aujourd'hui est plutôt avec
monsieur bibeau et ses liens étroits
avec jean charest très très près dit un
autre témoin comme des frères ici
mathieu prost radio canada montréal